if the world warms by six degrees from a
distance the oceans may appear bright
blue but they are marine wastelands
deserts March across continents like
conquering armies natural disasters
become common events
some of the world's great cities are
flooded and abandoned
this could be our world +6 degrees
warming's of six degrees over longer
time periods have been associated with
some of the most devastating mass
extinctions which have ever taken place
so it's certainly fair to assume that if
temperatures soar by 6 degrees within
less than a century that we're going to
face nothing less than a global wipeout
six degrees of warming has been called
the doomsday scenario our lives would
never be the same again